so my name is John masters I'm a
computer architect at Red Hat in my
normal day-to-day job
I'm not mitigating security
vulnerabilities but so so my day-to-day
job is trying to make armed servers a
thing taking over the world I work with
a lot of the high performance um be 8
server companies on their high
performance server designs and as a
consequence of working on that for the
past what six seven years and helping to
define the standards for the server
soces and the firmware and everything
from interconnects on up I've learned a
lot and others inside the company have
learned a lot about architecture and
micro architecture and so what I wanted
to do here was first share some thoughts
not everyone here is a micro architect
so there will be some introductory
material and then what I wanted to do
was to talk a little bit about the
infamous security vulnerabilities that
we can't stop reading about in the in
the media today I'd like a fairly
interactive format here so you said I
could run it however I want so I think
what I'm gonna do is if you guys have
thoughts please express yourselves if we
end up in a lengthy tangent then we'll
we'll come back to it later towards the
end okay so I'm gonna go through some
material on kind of architecture I'm
gonna talk about these particular
exploits but as we just alluded in the
introduction there there are many
different kinds of vulnerability out
there in particular when you take a look
at any kind of digital system and you
think about it outside the box outside
of how it was intended to be used so the
microphone example just now all these
devices capturing your voice yes they
can hear your your secrets your
passwords as you communicate they've
even done analysis reconstructing what
you're typing just by feeling the
vibrations from your phone being on a
table so we'll talk about side-channel
attacks but you know they're not unique
to microarchitecture you'll see
side-channel attacks
in many other places in everyday life
and if you want to get hold of me you
can tweet me maybe during the talk you
can email me reach me on all the social
media so we'll talk about meltdown
inspector there's the graphic that we
have to use so you guys have seen that
shall we continue so we'll cover the
difference between architecture and
microarchitecture I will talk about in
order and out of order execution we will
layer on top of that and talk about
speculation and how that works
some people here I'm glad I don't see
NSE here or anyone who would really
correct me but some of you know this far
better than I do and you can feel free
to correct anything that you you think I
get wrong we'll talk about we'll talk
about caches we'll talk about virtual
memory we'll talk about all the pieces
that you need to have some understanding
of in order for this to make sense and
then we'll get into branch prediction
speculative execution these particular
exciting vulnerabilities that we've been
contending with and then maybe some
that's not so much juicy gossip but
maybe some insights into how we mitigate
these when we're confronted with the end
of the world being nigh and what do we
do about that and then we'll talk about
some related research right because
these are just two of many kinds of not
so novel but but kinds of hardware
attack and as a software person myself
you know it's one of the things that
Madden's me someone said why is the Red
Hat guy here right so one of things that
Madden's me about this industry is that
we've gotten into an us-versus-them over
the past few decades so you're either a
software guy or you're or girl or you're
a hardware guy or girl and never the two
shall meet right and I would really like
it if we could change that but please
sure sure yeah yeah it wasn't a personal
I have buyer's remorse I did computer
science and I think if I did my time
over again I may have pursued a
different paths in my career I'm not
sure if I'd be doing the same talk but
it would have been very interesting
so I find I find architecture for
interesting I think one of the other
things that open-source people have
found over the past few years of seeing
you know open-source architectures like
RISC 5 and so on there's there's a
renewed interest and how does it work
inside and as an everyday you know
engineer you may not have access to a
fab you certainly don't have access to
the kind of design tools that you need
but you know some of us you know play
around pretty seriously with Vera log on
the weekend and build some interesting
designs and it's amazing where this is
going now anyway let's talk about
architecture so this is a refresher for
anyone who's not familiar with the
background material so we're gonna talk
about the difference being architecture
and micro architecture so computer
architectures or instruction set
architectures describe the contract that
the programmer has with the hardware
right they describe the primitive
operations that the machine accountant
must support they include things like
you know loading and storing data from
memory the memory model of the machine
how that works
how many registers you have in your
machine you know how the stack behaves
how branches and control flow
instructions operate adds subtracts you
know the usual kinds of operations they
also define separate execution
environments so you have a user or
unprivileged to a problem state
depending on which architecture you're
on and what nomenclature is being used
and then you have a more privileged
state that the operating system exists
in right and people who are not sort of
operating system folks tend to think of
an OS as always being there right
running the pharisee in the background
but that's not really true what we do
most the time is try to get out of the
way and that the application run right
and so some
the exploits you're gonna hear about
they rely on the fact that we have these
optimizations in place that make it
really easy to have the OS come in and
get out of the way really quickly so you
have the you have the concept of
exception levels or different contexts
that the operating system and the
application are existing in and then the
operating system has a more privileged
state has access to some additional
registers it can do a few more things
than the application can do for example
it can switch out one process for
another has to change some housekeeping
processor registers to do that
and you know the architecture is the
lowest level targeted by an application
programmer or these days more commonly a
compiler you know or some kind of
runtime environment right there are
fewer and fewer people actually writing
assembly code these days but if they are
then the architecture specification is
what they are targeting so common
concepts in modern architectures
application programs when they're
running are known as processes in Linux
we call them tasks and then they exist
inside this unprivileged exception
environment this unprivileged execution
context they exist inside a virtual
memory environment as well so the memory
that an application is using is virtual
in nature it's translated from the
address the application is using our
into the underlying address of the
physical memory and that's done through
a piece of hardware called the memory
management unit and we'll talk a little
bit more about how that's done in a few
slides
the point of this is that the operating
system provides this illusion of having
this flat contiguous nice virtual memory
you know you're not aware of other
programs that are running you think you
got the whole machine to yourself you
can kind of write your program and just
you know have have all these assumptions
that we're not true in the early days of
computing for sure and then when the
application is running what it does is
period
it interacts with system software it
interacts with the operating system
using something we call system calls so
we have depending on the architecture a
special instruction that we can we can
use and we provide some information and
some registers that say I'd like you to
do this for me and then come back and
importantly towards the bottom of the
slide here I in Linux certainly until
recently although we'll come on to why
that's changed until fairly recently the
way it worked is you had this huge
virtual memory space and so what you did
was you had this optimization you linked
to your application your application
used the bottom part of the virtual
address space and your operating system
kernel use the top half and you relied
on the standard memory management unit
protections to say if I try to touch
some of that memory that's reserved for
the OS I'm gonna get an exception I'm
gonna get some fault condition the OS is
going to intervene it's gonna say you
can't do that it's gonna kill my program
when we get further down the road
towards meltdown we'll talk about how
that's not necessarily true and why we
had to change that okay so some more
concepts so we have we have privileged
instructions we can use to manage the
environment I'll talk more about how
page tables work and how we do virtual
memory translation in a few moments one
of the things that we do whenever we
switch from one task to another is we
write into a CPU register on x86 it's
called cr3 on arm systems we call it a
translation table based register tt Br
it has different names on different
architectures and you could you could
say that that defines the memory context
about that one process is running it and
when I write a new set of page tables
I've switched from one program to
another the operate systems responsible
for doing that it does it completely
invisibly from the applications point of
view and again when an application tries
to access memory that it doesn't have
permission to use
what should happen is a fault should be
generated we call them page faults this
is why so we use page faults quite
extensively in operating systems we use
them for example when you load when you
start running a program your favorite
web browser whatever you're using right
it won't actually load the entire
contents of that application into memory
what we'll do is we'll start running it
as it starts trying to touch starts
trying to execute its code will trigger
page faults will pull more of that
application in the application won't
have any awareness that that's going on
right so page faults are good they're
not a bad thing we use them all the time
the other way we use them is when we
want to page or swap data out to disk we
give this illusion that machine has more
memory that in fact does because we can
pick we can temporarily take memory
that's in that's David that's in memory
we can put it out onto the disk when the
application tries to touch it again we
set it up so that triggers a fault we go
and fix it up right these are the common
techniques that we use examples of
architectures these are just - you know
you have to give the Intel example right
who here has never used an Intel machine
right okay so so clearly you have to
give x86 I'm a big fan of armed v8 I
could have gone with RISC 5 decided not
to it's a bit too easy to use that
example at this point but these are
examples of two different kinds of
architecture
they both do similar things back in the
day you would certainly define them we
talked earlier about how that's not
necessarily true inside but you would
define them in terms of whether one was
sisk ones a complex instruction set
architecture the other one is a reduced
instruction set architecture a RISC
architecture which means the
instructions are simpler and in
particular some of the differences here
on an x86 machine the instructions are
variable size decoding them is exciting
as we're talking about outside you know
I think you can have up to 15 bytes long
and then some of the decoders out there
will pull 16 bytes at a time and try to
slice and figure out which one goes
where
and the decode is crazy on these things
right but fundamentally you know x86 is
variable-width arm is a fixed-width
instruction set they both have registers
that they use for their calculations in
the case of a more complex instruction
set like x86 it might be at a directly
operate on memory I in the case of arm
and and RISC architectures they're more
load store or interred so you will
specifically pull data in to a register
and do something with it and then write
the result back and they're both 64-bit
pretty clean these days x86 used to have
a storied history of how it handled
memory hands up here if you enjoy
segmentation right ok so so but you know
though it wasn't always as clean as it
is now in the 64-bit architecture AMD 64
when when AMD made the original 64-bit
extensions it kind of killed off a lot
of that there's still some vestigial
segmentation unfortunately not enough to
get us out of the little problem we'll
talk about later just enough to be there
but not enough to be useful I you can
i'll yeah I don't need to far ahead but
you actually you actually could for some
32-bit processors that still have
segmentation we think of mitigation
could be to place like mentation
register hacks we can come back to it
correct correct correct yes so we right
and putting that on the stack we're
going to come back to that okay so these
are two different architectures let's
talk about microarchitecture this is
when the software guy gets wrong right
okay so before I get in too far into
microarchitecture I want to show you
just a very very boring diagram that I
put together you know modern processors
modern chips right they're not just a
CPU they're not just processor course
there's a bunch of extra stuff on there
most the ones that we deal with the far
more complex than this
the key point is they don't just have
processors they also have memory
controllers memory interfaces they have
multiple cores connected together
probably using a high-performance
interconnect moment hope and they have
multiple levels of cache all right so
when I'm operating on data inside a
modern processor environment
I've got memory that's pretty far away
from my core and then I've got
progressively larger levels of cache as
I get further away from the compute core
that's doing the work and as I work on
data what I'm doing is I'm pulling it in
through the cache hierarchy I pull it in
through the DDR through the memory
interfaces it goes into my fairly large
last level cache might be in l3 might be
no.4 and it works its way up to the l1
and we'll talk more about that in a
moment just take away from this that
processors are more than just coarse so
the elements of a typical chip today you
know programmers think of processors in
terms of course right some of them are
multi-threaded some of them may actually
do very tight resource sharing some
don't in the case of very tight resource
sharing then really what you're doing is
you're saying my core is more than one
core I'm gonna give you the minimum
amount of state to present that as
having more than one core that'll be
important for some things we discussed
later the cores are tightly integrated
with these interconnection networks and
we pull data in through the cache
hierarchy I think I've said all that ok
ok so the term microarchitecture it
specifically refers to an implementation
of an architecture right so we'll come
up with some examples later on but you
know you can think of your x86 as being
your architecture and then specific
Intel or AMD processors are
implementations of that architecture
that's microarchitecture and there are
many different kinds of ways to design
high performance processors probably
more ways to design low performance
processors I guess when you think about
it
but at a high level we can talk about
some standard concepts so you can have
inorder implementations in order
microarchitectures which we'll talk
about first and in a way they're simpler
certainly the design is less complex but
there can be benefits too in order
designs a lot of the folks out there
that have inorder designs are now saying
we're not vulnerable to some of these
exploits that's great they're maybe not
as performant as some of the others that
are vulnerable but in order designs also
can save you a lot of power so they have
a lot of benefits they're heavily used
in embedded systems they're not wrong
they're just different and then we also
have out of order course which are
designed really to take your in order
program we'll talk more about how this
works in a minute take your in order
program and turn it into a dataflow
machine which will we'll talk about as
well so modern processors as we were
discussing outside before particularly
the Intel ones right they take these
complex instructions they decode them
they turn them into a RISC machine
inside they throw them out of order and
run them in whatever order makes sense
when data becomes available and then
they lie to the programmer and the
average software engineer I talked to
and you know talked about out of order
machines and dataflow machines they say
what I run the program and it it does
stuff and you know precise exception
knows knowing that you know just magic
right it's magic well let's talk a
little bit more about how that magic
works really bad diagrams I'm not a
graphic artist the internet has better
diagrams there are whole classes on in
order and out of order machines so we'll
go through this pretty quickly but an
in-order core you know you can think of
your classic risk five stage pipeline
you fetch instructions you decode them
you execute them maybe perform some kind
of memory access and then you commit the
results back to a register file and you
rinse and repeat and you'll see in this
diagram that I've got two different
parts of my cache
represented here at the level one I
cache instruction cache from which I'm
fetching instructions that I want to
execute and I've got a level one D cache
from which I'm fetching data and then
further out away from the core you're
not seeing that here I have a unified
set of caches beyond that so when I want
to pull something into my level one on
my level two cache it'll actually come
from a unified level two and then from a
level three level 4 and so on why do I
split it out for performance reasons
partly for area when you're designing
and laying out a chip you know you you
you you effectively turn modern machines
into these Harvard architecture has
separated ind cache just because you
really can treat the instructions and
data separately that's a classic kind of
risk pipeline of the kind that you would
see in the computer architecture books
although their diagrams might be better
than mine there's some examples here of
how you would decode and execute an
instruction you know and how it behaves
I'll let you read that later on is a
visualization of how you would have an
inner or pipeline you can see some
parallelism here because in that middle
point there I've got this pipeline
that's completely filled with
instructions at different stages all
right so why do you do this you do this
because you can pipeline processors you
can have them you can have multiple
instructions in flight at different
stages in your pipeline now we'll talk a
little bit more about what happens if
you are executed putting instructions
through your pipeline and one is looking
for some data that's not yet ready we'll
talk a bit more about how how we handle
that I think that's in the next slide so
yes so in order microarchitecture the
key sort of downsides to them is that
you're subject to pipeline stalls so if
I am running a whole bunch of
instructions through my different stages
of my pipeline if one of them takes a
bit longer if one of them is waiting for
some data to load from memory my diagram
disappeared on that screen but it's
still there okay
then then I may have to insert pipeline
bubbles I may have to just store the
processor and do no you
we'll work we are limited in our
capability to hide the latency of
instructions as a result let's talk a
bit more about out of order course again
it's a bad diagram of mine what we do
with out of order course is we pull
instructions in from our level 1
instruction cache we decode them and
then we have this reorder buffer I think
it's on my next slide here yeah so okay
well I'll talk through the diagram so we
pull instructions we want to execute we
have this giant data structure called a
reorder buffer and what we do is we say
I these later instructions can execute
the moment that their data dependencies
become available
that's what beta flow machines do all
right so we turn our program for being
in order do this and then this and then
this we say actually we can get a far
more efficient machine if we can look
ahead and we can see future instructions
could execute the moment that their
dependencies become available and
depending on how big you make these
structures you could actually have quite
a large number of instructions that are
outstanding we call this the window size
or a different terms are use for this
but on contemporary parts this could be
on the order of 224 instructions
something like this so it's a reasonable
number of entries in our in our Ryota
buffer it's common in high-performance
microprocessors we also call it dynamic
execution and for those looking for the
extra credit question was invented by
Robert Tomasulo who unfortunately passed
away a couple of years ago oh is it
really is that is that okay
when she left yeah okay correct this
light so I Tomasulo actually received a
number of awards and I think passed away
what two years ago something like this
couple years ago but you know very smart
man I do wonder what he would have said
about this you know and sadly we'll
never know but anyway I won't I won't go
I won't go through this line by line I
really want you guys to take the slides
later and I want you to you know take
anything out of them that's useful but
what we what we're doing with out of
order machines is we're separating our
our machine or our core into a front end
and a back end right we're taking in
order we're throwing it out there we're
doing it in a different sequence from
what the programmer how the program has
seized the machine and then we do what
we call inorder retirement so when
instructions become the oldest
instruction in the machine that's
currently got all of its dependencies
satisfied then we say this instruction
is now complete this instruction retires
we mark it as such in our reorder buffer
and I think I have a slide here yeah we
have this concept of having an
architectural state so in out of order
machines I'll have an architectural
register file this contains my my kind
of committed final state of the machine
I have my out of order intermediate
state that I'm capturing in my reorder
buffer and when instructions complete
they retire then I update my
architectural register file and finally
one last thing we can do with out of
order machines we can solve some
register pressure when my programmer
writes code they may be constrained to
15 registers 31 registers something like
this some of the calculations they
perform they're reusing a register
solely because they have a finite number
in there in the real physical machine
there may be more physical registers and
so I can resolve you guys probably know
all this stuff but you can resolve you
know hazard
by looking at do I really need this
exact register here or will any other
register do to satisfy the dependencies
for this future instruction so you can
do hazard elimination as well let's see
so questions you can ask about an
architecture I think got a couple
examples of architecture here yeah so
here's here's two sort of
microarchitectures side-by-side this is
a fairly well it was contemporary fairly
recently Intel skylake microarchitecture
which is what's in this laptop that's
why I'm using that example and then a
fairly recent IBM microarchitecture you
can see they've got some similarities
there's some differences the IBM
machines tend to issue far more
instructions per cycle they're much
bigger their design point is much higher
performance than a than a laptop part
they've got similar sized reorder
buffers IBM calls at a global completion
table but it's basically achieving the
same thing and yeah I think that's the
main stuff I want to point out there so
when it comes to micro architecture we
can ask questions about about
implementations we can see you know you
did an in-order design you did an
out-of-order design why did you do this
well it's trade-off a in order design is
smaller in terms of area uses less power
so you see those much more commonly in
simpler machines they can be much less
expensive to implement in terms of your
engineering team and your validation
effort you can also ask questions that
about you know how big is the pipeline
how many instructions can I dispatch and
then how big is my reorder buffer how
many how far ahead in time can I have
instructions in flight these are all
kinds of design decisions that you can
you can make trade-offs let's talk about
some virtual memory and cache concepts
so I said earlier on virtual memory is
what applications see so in this diagram
here you can see our two different
process
is running process a and process B these
are potentially two different programs
maybe two instances of the same program
maybe a Bitcoin miner that apparently is
what old machine should be used for
today well it's probably a GPU thing but
anyway so you've got two programs
running and the distinguishing piece is
the context that they have right so they
both see different register state they
both see different views of memory and
you've got your physical memory you've
got some kind of translation that
happens and that translation is done by
the memory management unit inside the
processor using page tables that are
managed by the operating system and the
page table management by the way it
doesn't have to be done fully in
Hardware you can do it in software
people have done it in software on
simpler course but for performance
reasons it tends to be a hardware
hardware structures in the chip that
read these and what they'll do is
they'll look at the page table and say
you wanted to access this virtual
address in your address space I'm gonna
do a translation I'm first gonna check
what the page table says in terms of do
you have permission to access this
address can you execute it can you read
it you know there's lots of different
pieces of data that's contained in the
page tables and then what will happen
yeah I think my next slide will point
this out what I'll do is I'll cache
these translations so walking page
tables is quite expensive it can take a
lot of different memory accesses because
the page tables themselves are contained
in memory and so I have something called
a translation lookaside buffer a TLB or
multiple TLB s-- that will cache the
last few translations and you know you
never have enough TLB entries but you
know you usually have room to keep
enough of your immediate working set
translations inside them so you don't
have to go through this expensive lookup
every time you do a translation so
memory addresses are translated possibly
multiple times before they reach memory
so the operating system might do it if
there's a hypervisor the OS thinks it's
the last translation stage it's actually
not there's a hypervisor underneath it
doing that
could be other stages of translation as
well
the operating system manages the page
tables the hardware manages the tlbs
and sometimes this coordination needed
there for example when I switch from one
process to another I may need to
invalidate some of that state my
operating system will say I want to
shoot down the entries there from the
last process that was running so that
when I go to hex 1000 memory address
next time it's now for a different
address space and we were speaking
earlier about some optimizations I'm
gonna keep pointing to you because we
had a good conversation before we were
talking earlier about how there are some
optimizations in modern processors so I
don't have to completely flush every TLB
entry when I switch from one process to
another in particular arm has something
called a sets address space IDs x86 has
something called PCI IDs process context
IDs so when I'm running a particular
process I can actually tell the hardware
here's a unique identifier and it will
tag the TLB entries and so when I switch
when I do a lookup it can say well
here's the current value of my address
space that I think I'm in and I'm gonna
look that I look up in the TLB which
address space am i in which address
space is that entry in you have a
question on that one of the problems was
that sometimes the TLB at 4k pages
couldn't even address all of l3 cache
right now you're splitting it is that
well we have larger size than yeah we
have a lot of constructs we use in in
software we have huge pages gigantic
pages transparent huge pages lots of
different ways that we can underneath
say we're going to actually use a large
or TLB entry we get us that after but
there they're at their optimizations you
can do
so okay right yeah well so this is why
in my day job trying to make arm servers
a thing and they will be I've really
pushed for 64k as the minimum granule
size as they call it because I think if
you're building a new architecture it
doesn't really make any sense we'll talk
a bit later about how that can even
impact how your cash is organized so
we'll get there I'm going to keep
cranking because I guess time is getting
away from us but um anyway there's
there's some optimizations you can do in
your TLB s-- uh applications think they
own the world they don't they the
application binary the elf image in
Linux or the Peikoff in Windows or Mac
oh is that the format they use on OS 10
I'm not a Mac person I think that's the
format they use these application
binaries provide hints as to where to
load in virtual memory the application
when it starts up we map other things
into the virtual address space I
mentioned before that the OS until
fairly recently was mapped in the top
half of every address of every virtual
address space in fact in Linux it was
more than that the entirety of Ram was
mapped in every process at the top of
the virtual address space the official
things that we're providing the official
interfaces we're providing include
something in Linux called a virtual
dynamic shared object so the kernel will
actually provide certain data to every
process quite intentionally with the
idea that for example if all you want to
do is sit in a loop and read the current
wall clock time get time of day it would
be more efficient if I told you that
without you doing a call into the OS
every single time so we have this page
where we store a reasonable
approximation to the most recent wall
clock time and instead of doing the
system call we just read the data from
that so it's it's much more efficient so
there's other things we can do in in in
virtual memory you know kind of beyond
what you might you might already know
let's talk a bit more about caches
that screen keeps disappearing on me so
I kind of just want to make one one
point here this is this is about the
cache organization optimization piece we
almost got onto just now when I touch a
memory address a virtual memory address
what I'm needing to do is check if
that's in my cache during the access I
am what I might do is split how I how I
perform that cache access so I may
perform part of the translation of my
virtual memory to physical memory in
parallel with the cache access this is
actually where the page size piece comes
in because if you've got a 4k page size
in a machine for reasons you can read
about later on this actually will limit
the size of your cache for your level 1
cache so in a typical machine in a
typical machine I will have these cache
lines that contain that can contain
blocks of memory can contain blocks of
physical memory copies of it
I have protocols that will manage that
coherently and try to keep that the same
as keep a consistent view between what
the core sees and what is in the actual
RAM and then I have different ways I can
organize these caches there's the next
slide here like I said somewhere here
yeah so a common optimization is to use
VI PT caches so virtually indexed
physically tagged which is what this
diagram here talks about so I use the
low order bits of a virtual address to
start doing my cache look up when I
access an address at the same time I
translate the other half I do the actual
TLB translation to find the remaining
piece that I need so the first pile of
the lookup will tell me which index to
look in my cache and then I will check
every entry in that index
against the translation that I get in
parallel
and that's just one example of
optimizations that we do in caches it's
one reason that virtually index
physically tagged caches are very
popular especially at the level one
layer that's all I want to point out
there okay so why is this interesting
well caches can be used as what we call
side channels the whole point of a cache
is to provide a performance benefit to
provide a speed-up right caches are by
their nature shared resources between
multiple processors and they contain
data that's shared between multiple
different concurrently running programs
well no you can yeah you it's so so
you're both right the kernel is common
depending on how we map memory you also
can have some cache partitioning so
people have different names for this in
the industry intel calls it cat cache
allocation technology part of their
resource directory or technology other
companies have different things that
they do but what you can do is you can
say I'm gonna partition my cache and I'm
going to separate it and just give this
process this and this process there's
that can help you to an extent to
mitigate some of the side channel
attacks not meltdown but potentially
other side channel attacks in the future
but what a side channel really means is
because when we designed architectures
when we designed memory systems we
didn't really pay enough attention to
the time component right to the fact
that we can observe how long we conserve
the passage of time right how long does
a load take how long does an operation
take that hits in my cache or does not
hit in my cache and it's it's kind of
interesting you if you want you can
actually go online on github and you can
look I think it's
i AI K is the project you want to look
for the folks at tu grass who did some
of the work on these exploits I'll come
to you in a second
some of the folks that did the work on
this they actually published some really
interesting demo program so you can run
to measure different aspects of your
cache but what you can do is you can
literally measure how long does it take
to access a particular memory location
and from that you can infer is it in my
level one level two level three where in
my cache is it or is it not it actually
gets a bit more exciting let me come to
the well I'll come back to that but well
I'll foreshadow you can actually on some
on some processors you can actually you
have an instruction that will actually
flush an entry from the cash that's
unprivileged any application can do this
I can say on my Intel machine I can say
flush this memory location make sure
it's not in my cache and you can
actually time the amount of time it
takes to call the flush instruction and
from that you can infer was it in the
cache or not so the nice thing about
that is you never even have to try to
load something right so with the other
attack you have to at least try to you
know do a load time it do a load again
see if it was in the cache with the
flush you don't even have to do that
it's much harder to detect
I'll come back to that a moment here's
here's that here's kind of how you how
you would do it on most contemporary
processors there's either an instruction
to do this or there's other ways you can
you can achieve the same thing but you
you have a hype you have a very high
precision time stamp counter the TSC on
x86 machines I can read it I can do a
memory access I can read it again look
at the Delta write I can see was that
was was that location cached and we'll
come back to why that's important in a
moment you had a question before I keep
going do you want me to leave as long as
we had the problem that work we were
yeah there was the ability to disable
and you said we didn't pay enough
attention
I wasn't b5 right 56 right we didn't pay
enough attention to time I always wanted
you the OS guys also never happened so
what do you think that's right so I'll
take attention because attendants are
good I the the mitigation in Android one
of the mitigations we'll come back to
that so the the mitigation in Android by
the way one of the things they said lat
in December was we'll just turn off
access to high-precision timers will lie
well out these deltas will deal with the
statistical analysis part of it will
make it very very imprecise you can
still time how long things take you can
count cycles there's a lot you know I've
been pulling this out of them this is
great guys but there's so many ways you
can still you can still do this so
fundamentally anytime there it
unintended I guess anytime there is a
difference in the amount of time it
takes to do something and you can
observe it you can infer very
interesting things as a result so side
channels are very exciting they've been
getting a lot of research in the last
few years certainly as I said many
searching sets provide high resolution
cycle accurate timers yes yes well no
it's not it has to already be in the TLB
and I have a slide on that so will will
will will answer it correct correct
that's a very good question I'm putting
that in the stack as well because that
is a I have a
specific point on that that's that's
good you you depending on the
implementation you have to have it in
the TLB as well as the l1 cache the guys
at tu grass tell me no and every time
they tell me something I'm inclined to
listen to them so but for some of the
designs I've seen it certainly has to be
both in the TLB and the level one that's
the only way I can make fruit meltdown
yes and we'll come back to the let's
let's let's keep going we'll come back
to that clarify why knowing whether
something is in the cache right right
well so so I think for a lot of people
in in a building machines it was I
you guys paid attention I'm not picking
on a particular person here but you know
you might think well it doesn't really
matter right what we're gonna see the
next few slides is you know why that is
a key insight that that really makes
some of these attacks possible so so we
can we can measure cache behavior we
might have convenient instructions
they're very nice give me a CL flush
people say well why is CL flush there
why can't I flush stuff out of my cache
well the reality is I can also flush
something from the cache by doing what's
called a displacement flush I can make
another data structure that sits here I
happen to know where it's gonna sit in
my cache when I access it and so I don't
even need an instruction I can still
force things to evict from my cache
there's there's no way to hide from from
this yeah exactly
and I've got a row hammer piece as well
so this is cool
all right let's keep going some
processors also provide we touched on
prefetching it means to prefetch data
that will be needed soon usually through
hint instructions they might be we have
to go too much into not space stuff but
these instructions may or may not do
something right they they're their hints
I may use this beta sometime soon and in
fact you can time prefetches as well and
this actual became a problem in linux a
number of years ago because it would
insert a prefetch for pointers it was
about it was likely to use soon and it
was discovered that every time there was
a null
enter that prefetch would take too long
and so Linux removed the use of this
prefetch precisely because you could
actually infer the amount of time for a
pointer access so it's very interesting
that what we've seen over the last few
years so here's some examples of how you
would use prefetches let's keep going I
don't go to branch prediction so here's
a slide I think you guys probably don't
need it uh you know frequently we have
program control flow instructions where
we need to change the flow of execution
based on some condition right when if we
do this we're going to have a either
inconsequential or significant hit to
our pipeline depending on the outcome
right if we'll talk a bit more in a
moment about speculation but if I go
down a branch if I go down a path of
code execution and it's the wrong path
going back the right way you know the
Chinese proverb is no matter how far
down the wrong path you've gone turn
back right but that may be expensive so
there is some benefit in predicting
which way code is going to go and I'll
talk about two kinds of branch here
conditional branches which is really
your classic if statement if this value
then do this otherwise do that that
would be a conditional some instruction
sets lets you encode actually the likely
outcome from branches most x86
processors ignore those now because
actually it's better for the hardware to
figure it out but you you you will see
in OS software things like if likely
this well that will do nothing on most
processors now but it used to do things
okay okay so I'll touch on speculation
I'll come back to branch prediction of
it more so speculation is an extension
of I'm trying to cram a lot here into an
hour
speculation is an extension of
out-of-order machines right so so
speculation is basically layering on the
out of order mechanics that I have in my
machine and it's saying that if I
reasonably believe that I'm going to
execute a particular path of code follow
a branch then let's abuse the fact that
we have all this infrastructure to run
programs further ahead let's start
tagging entries in my Ryota buffer this
is before the instruction has retired so
before it's become architects revisit
ball let's tag them as speculative let's
say I'm not sure if that actually is the
way the program is going to go but let's
keep running it ahead let's tag these
instructions as being speculative in
nature the key things here are don't
update don't update the architectural
state don't make it visible apparently
that's the plan didn't quite work that
way but that was the idea and stores to
memory will be filed away in my internal
structures they won't actually make it
out to memory until that instruction
retires exceptions caused by my code
that's running speculatively will not be
raised until retirement until the
instruction actually becomes committed
then I can't report something that may
not happen right you try to load
something but you didn't actually
because they did it speculatively I
can't blame you for that because I don't
know if that's the thing you actually
want to do right so I have to tag that
also in my reel to buffer and say that I
have an exception if this becomes the
path that I'm really going to take then
I may have to deal with that well that's
the that's that's the that's the piece
we're going to come to you and then some
people made a mistake with that yeah I
came first
yeah I think it did because how he did
every company is evolving and many
microcontrollers are gonna work out and
have speculation right right absolutely
why men run ahead as well in order
sheets are new yeah well I don't think
they by the way I don't think they are a
lot of them Thunderball as well yes yes
right that's kind of one of the things
I'm trying to say here
okay so branch prediction let's come
back to that so if I'm if I'm
implementing prediction of branches what
I'm going to do is I'm going to look at
a particular branch and I'm gonna say
let me let me speculate that it's going
to go this way right so if that's true
then I start tagging the instructions as
speculative I followed down the path and
hopefully all things are good if it's
not the way the code actually ends up
going right so so I'm got this condition
I'm waiting for the branch to resolve
and waiting for the condition to to find
out if this branch is going to be the
way I go if it was incorrect then I have
to throw away everything I did I'll have
to return my state there's some
optimizations for how to do that but
have to return my state to where it was
and I'll have to go down the correct
branch and what you hope is that there's
a performance hit from doing this
although it's small and you this is a
black box so in theory it's not visible
to anybody else we'll come on to how
that's not necessarily true I've got a
couple of slides here I might skip an
interest of time about conditional and
indirect branches but you know these are
examples of conditional branches for
example you could have a loop load a
value into a register you know run
through a loop you compare the condition
every time and you may jump backwards r2
to repeat the loop well someone's going
to point this out but actually you know
common common processors have
optimizations so you don't actually have
to deal with loops and in reality um
there's a lot of correlation
between branches and programs right so
one of the insights that people
designing processors found is that if
you look at history you can guess which
way you're gonna go in the future right
you can say the last few times I
executed this well this looks a lot like
a loop and as you'll see later you know
some processors will just have a loop
predictor and they will say well this is
obviously a loop I'm not even going to
bother with with the standard hardware
for that but you'll look at a branch and
you'll say the last hundred times I
executed this I went that way right
there's a high chance I'm going to do
the same thing next time so we have
these predictors which will tag the
history of a particular path of
execution particular way a branch went
and they will try to infer where it is
going to go the next time they can be
very complicated in their design so you
know a good predictor could be up to 99
percent accurate and it may use both
local branch information as well as
global branch information so in other
words there's a number of pieces of
research that suggests that branches
don't behave in isolation this
intuitively makes sense if I have a
bunch of conditions one after the other
they are dependent on that chain so I'm
a tag I'm a keep track of the overall
set of branches in in this hardware
structure the branch predictor hardware
what I also want to do is I want to
optimize it I want to keep track of
which way branches went but I want to
save resources I want to save using huge
amounts of RAM on the processor so I may
not use the full address of an
apprentice a branch in my branch
prediction hardware so I'm going to keep
the history of branches but I'm going to
either hash that branch address or I'm
going to use just part of the branch
address and keeping track of history
this is a key insight to why why Spectre
happens that we'll get to in a minute
yes
that's what the code is it's it's
virtual memory when the program is
running so you UK oh you're right you
can that's true enough you can you can
tag on a physical address I'm just
talking about one kind of implementation
it's true enough you can actually do
well well we should we should take this
after cuz cuz III certainly have some
some things I can't talk about here that
relate to that but but you're right
people do sometimes use physical
addresses you can still have problems
for that reason and also because frankly
I can write code that you know I can
it's pretty difficult to do but I can
arrange for the same physical address to
get used in two different places that
it's possible but we maybe we'll come
back to that in the Q&A session I want
to point out anyone who's not sort of
studied branch predictors go and read I
read the slides after you'll see gshare
and some of these common designs that
are used in in branch prediction
hardware we want to optimize it so we
might not use the full address we also
do indirect branch prediction so
indirect prediction is when I follow a
function pointer into into a virtual
method something like this I don't know
where I'm going to go ahead of time it's
not just a conditional branch it could
be a branch to anywhere there's also
some fairly fancy hardware that can
guess ahead of time where indirect
branches are going to go they turn out
to be you know in the spectral
literature they talk a lot about
indirect branches but actually direct
branches can also be a problem but we'll
find out more in a minute about why
indirect branches are a particular
source of a problem when you can abuse
them and that's because indirect
branches could really jump to anywhere
right I'm foreshadowing a bit but I want
you to think there's different kinds of
branches different kinds of predictors
the average microprocessor will have
many many different predictors and they
may all have to come to a consensus
there may be another
meta predictor that decides which which
one's the correct one to use okay let's
keep going I think I'm gonna let you
guys read that later on so let's I think
we've got enough the background so let's
go into meltdown inspector now so we get
time to get to questions so so these
vulnerabilities and their CVE numbers
are there
these are branded vulnerabilities that
were discovered in common industry-wide
optimizations of the techniques I just
described right there's nothing
inherently wrong with you know branch
prediction or speculation or out of
order machines they're all good ideas
the problem is that some implementations
have been found to be vulnerable to side
channel analysis and the media is very
keen to say that it's the end of the
world you know the media is very keen to
say lots of things and that usually
happens when you have a branded
vulnerability that comes with a cute
logo right we we we we knew but by the
way so I knew it was the guys at tu
grads working on this because for
reasons and so I actually sent them an
email a few weeks ago and I said you
know guys when you register Internet
domains don't use your own name and your
institution because if I'm watching you
since some time before your public
disclosure and I'm looking at everything
you register I might see when you
register these cute domains so they've
actually changed the registrations and
remove their names from it now but I did
enjoy doing a side channel analysis yeah
we knew what was coming
yeah we're able to infer the the name
before they before they launched it
that's that's a cute side story for you
so they came with cute names and logos
which always is worrying
they exploit these features but we don't
have to panic and throw out all of our
toys right we don't have to get rid of
them we just have to deal with these if
you are on a linux or when
machine if you're running a very recent
Linux kernel you could run that command
and you would see we now have a fun
directory filled with CPU
vulnerabilities because we think there
might be more in the future and so now
there's a handy-dandy way to find what
is your chip vulnerable to today right
and what are we doing to fix it
so maybe maybe look that up later on and
it will also tell you which mitigations
are being used on your hardware
if you're on Windows there's things you
can do if you're on a Mac I have no idea
I think you can do something so let's
talk through the the specter and
meltdown variant so Spectre variant one
we just knew these by the way as
variants one two and three for a long
time
right they got the cute names later we
were guessing what they would be but we
only ever knew of the three main
variants so yeah the both Spectre v12
and to an extent meltdown they rely on
particular code sequences right as I
said if if to your question about you
know why is it important if you can tell
what's in the cache
well maybe I'll maybe I'll jump to the
the the meltdown piece and we'll come
back to Spector maybe that will help
actually let's do meltdown first we'll
come back to Spector so meltdown
effectively if you are a literal
implementation of Tomasulo if you are
literally implementing it sort of by the
book and you haven't read Appendix B of
computer architecture page 37 or around
there where it talks about this and how
not to do it then you may you may handle
any exceptions that arise at instruction
retirement so that's the first piece
second pieces you may do your permission
checks in parallel with actually
performing any kind of load that's the
second piece of that's the other piece
that you need and then if you do that a
race condition could exist
between what you you you did you did
this load you're not allowed to do it
but I did it for you anyway I tagged it
so if that instruction ever actually
retires then we're good I'm gonna take
an exception and the OS is gonna slap
you and say don't do that and it's gonna
kill your program but in that window
there there is a period of time where
that load has happened and future
instructions might be able to do
something with it so what could they do
well here's an example this is from my
own reproducer so I spent um tail end of
last year I didn't sleep much for the
last few months and buy my Fitbit knows
that it said your heart rates 20 percent
higher than yeah I know so we've been
sort of neck-deep in mitigations for a
long time here what what semi reproducer
here is very very ugly but what it does
is basically say look I'm going to try
to access a pointer I shouldn't be to
access I'm then going to take the value
that I read that I can't read but I can
because I'm not going to handle that
right now and I'm going to do some mask
I'm gonna do something with that value
and I'm then gonna access another piece
of data based on the value of the data
that I wanted to read right the actual
content of the privileged data that I
wanted to read right and if I do it this
way there are better ways to do it
that's the way I did it I can say I'd
like to read this single bit from some
privileged data that I don't have access
to right I'll load the value I'll figure
out which bid I want I'll mask it off is
it a one is it a zero if it's one I
access one memory location if it's
another if it's a zero access the other
memory location then I have some code
that sits there in its own sweet time
measuring how long it took to read from
one location or the other and since I've
pre flushed those ahead of time I know
that neither of them is in my cache I
can then measure to see which of those
two is in my cache
and I can see what the speculative load
was if I rinse and repeat this many many
times then I can dump memory effectively
and I can dump pretty much you know
whatever I want now there are some
conditions as we talked about that that
may or may not have to be present so I
found on some unnamed architectures
because it's not just there's lots of
architectures impacted here on some
implementations are of speculation it
may be not as aggressive you may have to
have the data in the l1t cache you may
have to have a TLB for that address
already that's not a given actually but
but those conditions may be required I
think yeah so you know so so I'm I'm I'm
separating the the privilege check from
the actual data access as a consequence
I can infer what values are there and by
the way I do the accesses in in I didn't
put it in there I do the accesses in
reverse order because the hardware does
lots of other things underneath it it
has a thing called prefetching where
it'll it'll say well you access this
location you probably access the next
cache line very soon so I'm actually do
them in Reverse to try to fool it
probably they they're smart anyway and
figure that out as well but I'm able to
read memory very slowly with my
implementation the one that you'll see
publicly from the researchers I think is
much more performant but they both
achieve the same thing let's go to the
how you mitigate meltdown that's a good
point well I can try to I could try to
unwind that a little bit so you know
I've got this value I want to read right
I've got this privileged value I want to
read and you know it's it consists of
bits it consists of say 32 bits of data
right what I can do is I can read one
sub bit one bit of that data at a time
in this
in my particular attack what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna take the the the value
that I'm not entitled to access I'm
going to take each little bit of that
value and I'm going to individually work
out what the value of that bit was and
I'm going to do it by not masking it off
by by taking only the bit I want and
based on that single bit I'm going to
perform a second memory access which I'm
going to time okay and then in my it's
in my implementation i reconstruct all
32 bits of every single piece of memory
i want to read by repeating this many
many times there are more efficient
implementations that exist that actually
read memory much faster than this
example and they do a in the the
implementations is much faster right
this is this was me in in december
frantically trying to figure out how the
heck does this work and not having any
of the public you know information so I
think we're I think we're we're running
on time that's why I'm trying to keep
keep going here so okay I'm going to
talk about the specter variant one
invariant to I'm sorry okay sorry
indication okay okay so mitigating
mitigating meltdown
okay so mitigating meltdown you know as
I said the there there are certain
preconditions required to exploit
meltdown you have to have you have to
have the condition in which the data is
accessible to the code that may run
speculatively if you can remove the
environment from which speculating code
can actually perform that load then you
can prevent you know you're not fixing
it you're not fixing the silicon but
you're mitigating it you're making that
those circumstances are impossible and
so one of the primary mitigations that
we use that's expensive is we change how
we set up the operating system page
tables and we split them so instead of
having a page table for every
application that shared with the kernel
that that's shared with the operating
system what I do now is I have for every
program I have one set of page tables
for the program and one set of page
tables for the operating system for the
kernel every time I go into the
operating system to do something I
switch the page tables so there never
it's never the case that I have the same
virtual memory environment active is
never the case that I would have kernel
addresses visible from the from the
applications address space I double up
my page tables and I take this expensive
hit every time I go into your out of my
kernel I have to do a switch yes well I
mentioned earlier there's an
optimization PC IDs and assets so I
might not have to flush all of them
that's why on x86 for example processors
with the PC ID feature are going to
become much more interesting now because
it's multiple performant to implement it
when you have access to to these
features
accessible correct because in we had
this whole debate I mean I think I'll
think I'll save that question for for
for later because I know we're running a
long time yeah we we should we should
keep going because I want to I want to
cover the specter variant 1 & 2 if I can
in the time we have so so let's not
expect a variant 1 specter variant 1 is
a bound to check by pass in in effect
what I do is I say I'm a I'm a have some
piece of data some some information
passed from one context to another so
for example from application into the OS
kernel to the operating system and
normally what I do is I would perform a
bounced check from that to sanitize it
and say I you know the user the
untrusted user gave me some value I
should check if it lies within the
defined range however the program may
continue to execute speculatively beyond
that bounced check meaning that if I
were to find and the code here don't
worry too much about this exact code
because it's pretty much the same kinds
of code that you'll see for the meltdown
attack the point is if I can find a
piece of code in that's already present
in in the operating system that already
accesses some theory does this kind of
load sequence we talked about just now
so I have to find a gadget I have to
find some piece of code we called them
we call them gadgets I have to find some
piece of code in the kernel that's gonna
do what I want has to be there if I
don't if it's not there I can't do this
but in the case of variant 1 of Spectre
if I can find some little gadget where I
give you some unsanitized value and
you're gonna keep speculating and you do
some other load that impacts the cash I
might under very obscure circumstances
possibly be able to read something and
reproducing this is a huge problem it's
very very complex very very difficult
it's it's been
kind of in the abstract like one time
right that's enough to put it in a paper
and and be a huge problem but but
actually creating expected variant 1
attacks is very difficult right we can
we can mitigate specter by inserting
what we call context serializing
instructions so we can say after some
bounce check condition I can put a
special instruction that normally exists
in most architectures that's going to
prevent the speculation beyond there
it's expensive but there are ways I can
do it and the way I would do it is that
and in the case of x86 that's called elf
fence it varies my architecture but the
only way to really mitigate this by the
way is to go through my my software and
actually change it right there are some
tools out there that can go through and
some compilers are being modified to go
and insert these sequences but right now
the mitigation is go and identify where
these offending code paths are and we
have source and binary scanners to do
this it's not easy
go find where these are and go insert
the right serializing instructions in in
just the right places it's it's it's
it's painful the side channel this this
doesn't have a specific side channel
what you're doing here is you're you're
looking you have to find a piece of code
that already does something that you
want it to do speculatively so if you
look at the previous example we use with
meltdown performing a performing an
access that you shouldn't be able to do
and then using that value to do
something else you have to have a piece
of code already present that that is
vulnerable by by doing by having a
sequence of vulnerable instructions so
it doesn't just exist in in in the wild
you have to have a specific set of code
that's in a more privileged application
that you can exploit using this attack
yeah it's the same it's the same common
theme yeah it's the same common theme
it's all cash timing it's all the same
it's all the same attack its its
variations as mean as that's why they
called it variance right so yes if you
can find one and and let's keep going
because I want to I want to finish the
video piece then we'll get into the open
discussion so for for variant 2 what i
can do as i mentioned earlier branch
predictor branch predictors may not
fully disambiguate between different
branches I may have a branch predictor
in which two different applications
running in two different virtual memory
address spaces could have branches at
the same virtual addresses that the
branch predictor can't really tell apart
right so what I can do
inspector variant two is I can write a
very crafty application which when it
runs is going to train the branch
predictor to think that branches in in
the future are going to go a particular
direction and in the case of indirect
branches where it could be an offset it
could be guessing a an offset what I can
do is I can train the branch predictor
to speculatively jump to some offset
that I have control over if that offset
is a gadget the same as variant one then
what I can do is I can have even more
control now I don't have to look for a
specific entry point into my privilege
code I can now look for any code
sequence anywhere it doesn't have to be
beginning of a function end of a
function anywhere I can look for any
place where I see the instructions I
want to exploit and I can have an
application which will train my branch
predictor so that when I net when I next
run my kernel code on my OS code it
thinks a particular branch is going to
go
it's going to is going to is going to
result in a piece of gadget code running
now creating the environment respective
variant to is even harder than Spectre
variant one and if you read the paper
that the Google guys published they were
able to do this like one time and it
took you know what is it two hours of
set-up time and a very special
environment very contrived system that
they had full control over and and so
you know the reality is this is very
very difficult to exploit at this moment
in time if it sounds difficult it is
very very difficult to exploit this so
you can do both you can have us you can
have a an exploit across hyper threads
if you've got a threaded core there's
also a very strong attack path there and
I'll actually touch on that in a moment
but that is also a significant problem
as well if you're using hyper threading
I want to keep going because I know
we're running on time and we can take
this to a open discussion what we did
initially to mitigate variant two we
used a big hammer initially so the big
hammer approach was simply to turn off
the branch predictor when we were going
from one state into another that was
less that was more privileged yes that's
what we do so
so in fact ok I'm gonna let you read
about the millah code stuff later but on
x86 what we did was we implemented
something called IBRS indirect branch
restrict speculation and so on entry
into the kernel we we touched this magic
control bit this model specific register
and we turn off indirect branch
speculation while the kernel is running
when we come back out of the kernel we
come back to the application we turn it
back on again that's expensive because
we don't get the benefit of branch of
the branch predictor and even more than
that we we we have the cost of actually
doing that operation
that operation is not inexpensive right
yes maker so okay so we have another
another interface we added called IAB PB
which flushes the branch predictor state
so what we do is we have exactly that we
have a separate instruction and they
could implicit be implemented the same
right there's different ways you can
ferment it but but the second piece we
do actually will flush the branch
predictor state and we do that when we
switch from one process to another so we
turn off spec we turn off the branch
predictor briefly when we're going to go
into a more privileged state and we
whack the contents when we are switching
from one process to another I'm gonna
get - I think I'll touch on rep
Pauline's and then I think we can kind
of take the rest to an open discussion
so there is something that Google
invented are called rep Pauline's you
can read more about it later on but what
they do is they turn indirect branches
into fake function returns so they say
you know the old doctor joke right if it
hurts to do this and don't do it okay so
if it if you can abuse indirect function
calls to I with with a malicious
poisoning of your branch predictor
replace every indirect function call
with a different piece of code that
doesn't use that doesn't rely on the
same hardware and what what what Google
came up with was this construct and I'll
let you guys read the link to the paper
I won't there's not time to go through
the the code here but what what Google
came up with is this idea that
effectively I I i hack through the the
program state so that we think we're
returning from a function when we return
from that function what we're actually
going to do is we're going to call the
thing we wanted to call and they they
set this up so that you'll you'll see
there are those you guys see we're sort
of assembly folks you'll see that it
says capture specs what they do is they
they literally
set up the speculation so that it will
it will think it's in an infinite loop
calling a pause instruction branching to
itself in an infinite loop if it
speculates it's a cute hack the Google
guys are really great coming up with
that and as a result what we can do for
our respective variant two is we can
modify our compilers to emit this code
sequence instead of turning off our
branch predictor and that brings back a
lot of the performance that we we lose
by by using the the control interfaces
I'm going to keep going past I think
we're almost done with the kind of main
content there is a variant of melt there
is another variant covariant 3a which
lets you read registers you're not
supposed to access I'll let you guys
kind of go through that final prepared
slide I related research so you know
these these exploits don't exist in
isolation there's another set of attacks
we're done previously called row hammer
right which someone mentioned earlier
that's another example of a hardware
specific attack there's another yet
another interesting one I've seen are
called magic which they were able to
come up with particular sequences of
instructions which when you executed
them on a particular opensparc processor
could artificially age it which is
pretty crazy actually but they were able
to do it and they were able to reduce
performance by 10% in a matter of weeks
by running carefully-crafted instruction
sequences so the bottom line is you know
meltdown inspector are kind of
interesting right they're the flavor of
the month right now we're dealing with
those but there are tons of other pieces
of related research going on and and
novel attacks are being found all the
time well well you know I mean the thing
is that ones just an ACM paper and you
know no one gave it a cute logo right so
so I mean I'm very serious right that's
a last point I sort of I'll make is you
know yeah if you come up with
attack if you give it a cute name in a
logo you're gonna be on the New York
Times front page whether or not that is
you know you know Spectre variant too
frankly you know very very hard to
exploit meltdown much easier to exploit
you'll see all the reproducers show
meltdown first because that's the easy
one to get the meteor attention so with
that I am out of time for my slides and
I want to open it up and just take
questions and thank you thank you for
the video
you